staying in the U.S where the
government's released a nine point
strategy for research and development
into artificial intelligence the White
House wants to use AI to tackle Social
Challenges and limit the risk of misuse
Fenton Monahan explains why there's
pressure on the White House and what it
hopes to do
the Biden Administration has been under
pressure to come up with a plan to deal
with AI and that pressure is coming from
a place you'd least expected Silicon
Valley now Tech Pros aren't usually keen
on regulation but even the biggest Brew
of them all Elon Musk wants the
government to step in even the creator
of chat gbt the program that's captured
people's imaginations wants regulation
now the Biden Administration says it is
a plan top of the list of priorities is
investment to ensure the U.S remains a
leader in the field they want to help
create what they call an AI ready
Workforce
they also acknowledge the dangers of AI
potential biases privacy concerns
hacking vulnerabilities but this is a
strategic plan the details of how
they'll actually accomplish all this are
yet to come
on our White House correspondent
Kimberly hulkit has more on what the
Biden Administration is trying to
achieve
as the White House lays out its strategy
for ensuring that the United States
stays ahead of advancements in
artificial intelligence Democrats as
well as Republicans in the U.S Congress
are debating exactly how to regulate Ai
and when it comes to doing just that
there are a wide range of differing
opinions the top Democrat in the U.S
Senate Charles Schumer has recently
released a framework proposing that Tech
Giants should reveal their data sources
and explain models for their algorithms
that is something that Republicans are
pushing back on suggesting that this is
an overreach that could stifle
Innovation and even cut into business
profits recent hearings also failed to
put forward any sort of substantial
legislation proposals and as a result
that is why some top business groups
like The Chamber of Commerce in the
United States are calling for lawmakers
to work harder to come up with some sort
of legislative nation and in a hurry
that's because there are fears that
there could soon be a concern about a
loss for American businesses and even
threats to U.S national security
Kimberly Helk at Al Jazeera the White
House
Ramesh srinivasan is a professor
professor at UCLA's Department of
information studies he says regulation
could benefit the few AI companies
currently operating in the U.S
I'm very very concerned that a lot of
these calls for regulation and those
that seem to be driving discussions
around what such regulation would look
like in relation to artificial
intelligence are industry Titans right I
think it's worth noting that in the AI
space there are no it is not a very
competitive market it's just a couple
players in the United States primarily
Google and openai right and open AI has
a connection to Microsoft so when Sam
Altman or other industry execs go in
front of Congress and say we want
regulation what they're essentially
saying is set up a bunch of legal
parameters that are optimized for our
own success however there are aspects of
this call that are very important I
really hope they end up getting
prioritized which is what is the future
going to look like for workers in this
country let alone The Wider world when
digital systems are essentially able to
use the personal data of us all to mimic
our behavior and replace us in many
cases now is the critical juncture I
think it's partly because these AI
technologies that I'm specifically
referring to gpt4 gpt5 are just so
uncanny in their ability to mimic human
behavior and at times go off the rails
so I think that creates a lot of anxiety
for us all like what is this that we're
engaging with but your point is really
well taken the issues that a real public
interest real people-centered interests
real planet-centered interest of
regulation on these platforms on these
AI systems is actually very much the
same issue as what needs to be done with
our digital lives more generally and
absolutely with social media and search
as well